>>Male Presenter: Good afternoon. The term
"peer pressure" often carries negative connotations
of teens engaging in behaviors they otherwise
might not, or families going into debt to
keep up with their more affluent neighbors.
But in her book, "Join the Club: How Peer
Pressure Can Transform the World," Pulitzer
Prize winning journalist Tina Rosenberg, argues
there are powerful, sometimes overlooked,
benefits of peer pressure; that if peer pressure
can be an enticement for delinquent behavior,
it can also be an enticement for positive
behavior.
The fearless Tina Rosenberg has spent her
career tackling some of the world's most difficult
problems. Her powerful 1995 book, "The Haunted
Land" won both the National Book Award and
Pulitzer Prize for examining Europe after
the fall of the Iron Curtain.
She was also the first freelance journalist
to receive a MacArthur Fellowship Award. Imagine
Junior High kids out behind the gymnasium,
or in the locker room or bathroom, and instead
of smoking, they're talking about how they
can stay focused and get good grades in school.
Or, imagine a discussion around a village
well that centers on taking one's medications
faithfully to overcome disease. These are
the types of clubs she talks about and I suspect
that after hearing her, you will also want
to join the club. Tina Rosenberg.
[applause]
>>Tina Rosenberg: Thank you, Phil. Thank you
Google for having me here today and to you
all for coming to this talk. How many of you
have children? Anybody? This is a younger
crowd than I'm used to talking to.
Well, even if you don't have kids, you probably
know all about peer pressure. It's something
to worry about, right? We all know that if
our kids have problems, if they get drawn
into drugs, have a brush or two with the law,
if they're acting out, even if they just go
to the wrong parties, that's due to peer pressure.
But what if our kids do fine? What if they're
studying hard and acting respectfully and
spending their spare time volunteering? The
credit goes to your children, right? And to
you for excellence in parenting. That can't
be the result of peer pressure, can it? My
book is about something we’ve been familiar
with all our lives, but I hope it will provoke
you to take a new look.
We all know how mighty peer pressure is and
we're accustomed to being afraid of it. But
I argue that peer pressure can also be a powerful
force for good. In the book, I tell stories
of people in the United States and abroad
who are using peer pressure to solve problems
that could not be successfully attacked by
other means.
The case we all know is Alcoholics Anonymous
and it's a good example of what I'm talking
about. You help people to change their behavior
by giving them a new peer group, one that
supports them and holds them accountable,
one that they identify with.
The thesis of my book is that people are unlikely
to change their behavior because they receive
new information, or because you've told them
something that scares them to death. The most
effective way to persuade someone to change
is through identification.
Provide them with people just like them, who
have already made this change. I think we
can all imagine at a gut-level how effective
this can be for solving issues of personal
resistance to temptation. But the uses of
peer pressure are far broader.
And because of its effectiveness of scope,
this "join the club" strategy, which I also
call the social cure, opens up exciting new
possibilities for solving social problems
that we have come to think of as unsolvable.
Let me give you a few examples. In the late
1990s, teen cigarette smoking was astronomically
high in the United States.
In 1997, 36.5% of all high school seniors
smoked. This was really important because
young people are practically the only people
who start smoking. If you don't start by the
time you're 24, you're probably not gonna
start. And no one knew what to do about it.
We had tried stressing to kids how dangerous
cigarettes are, bombarding them with information.
We had tried appealing to fear, putting up
rows of gravestones on the billboards, telling
them "smoking kills." And none of it was working.
There was a headline in the Washington Post
in 1998 that said, "Officials seek a path
to cut into haze of youth smoking. The bottom
line, no one knows what works." Then the state
of Florida found something that worked spectacularly
well. It hired an advertising agency by the
name of Crispin Porter and Bogusky.
This agency had no experience at all with
public health, but it did know how to sell
to teenagers. Its staff sat down and looked
at the problem, not from a public health perspective,
but from the perspective of an ad man. Why
do teens start smoking? A cigarette, after
all, is a repulsive product.
No one would buy a cigarette for itself. Once
you start, you continue to smoke because you're
hooked. But why do teens start in the first
place? The answer is that for teens, a cigarette
is not a delivery system for nicotine. It's
a delivery system for rebellion. It's a way
for teens to tell adults, "I'm autonomous.
You don't tell me what to do."
It's a way for teens to look cool to their
peers and feel cool to themselves. That's
why the usual strategies don't work. Teens
already know that cigarettes can kill them.
In fact, teenagers overestimate the dangers
of smoking. They think cigarettes are even
worse than they are.
Clearly, that's part of their appeal for teenagers.
So, Crispin Porter's people thought, "What
if we make not smoking a way to rebel, with
the tobacco companies as the target?" They
designed a series of TV spots, most of them
written by teenagers themselves that showed
kids rebelling against these corporate manipulators.
They filmed teenagers making prank phone calls.
For example, to the advertising agencies that
worked on tobacco accounts. They filmed a
road trip, a group of kids who drove from
Florida up to Richmond, Virginia, which is
the headquarters of Phillip-Morris.
And when they got to Phillip-Morris, they
stop at the gate and they ask the guard if
they could see the Marlboro Man. And the guard,
who was clueless, told them, "Oh, I'm sorry.
You can't see him. He's just died." And in
fact, the actor who played the Marlboro Man
in Phillip-Morris' TV commercials had just
died of lung cancer.
And they got this all on film. Accompanying
the media spots was clubs that kids could
join, clubs whose focus was rebelling against
the tobacco industry. These clubs staged pranks
and actions. After Florida, the strategy went
national and I followed one group of kids
in South Carolina who were doing the same
thing.
This group was called Rage Against the Haze,
which gives you some idea of the tenor of
it. And they stage events at high school football
games and do things like take over the smoking
section at Shoney's restaurants. They never
attack smokers. They never say you shouldn't
smoke.
Or worst of all, they never say that cigarette
smoking is only for grown-ups. They just point
out to teens how the cigarette manufacturers
are manipulating them. This worked. It was
the first time in history that anything had
worked. Over the next two years, Florida saw
the single biggest drop in teen smoking that
the United States had ever seen.
The strategy went nation-wide two years later.
And until 2007, teen smoking nationwide continued
to drop. Florida's teen smoking rate was cut
in half in a decade and many other states
did just as well.
[pause]
Now that's an example of the social cure working
at a very personal level.
But it has also accomplished social change
on a very grand scale. Let's look at another
success of the social cure, a very different
kind of success, and one that's probably more
surprising, which is the fall of Slobodan
Miloševi? in Serbia.
In October of 1998, 1998 evidently being a
very good year for the social cure, a group
of about eleven students at Belgrade University
started to meet to plan to get rid of Miloševi?.
They called themselves "Otpor," which in Serbian
means "resistance." And they didn't do any
of the things that normal political movements
do.
Otpor did not see its job as giving Serbs
information about how terrible the dictatorship
was. Serbs already knew that. It was their
lives. They were living it. Lack of information
was not the problem. Instead, these students
defined their task as motivating people to
do something about it.
Serbs under Miloševi? were fearful and passive.
They felt powerless. They thought of themselves
purely as victims. The challenge for Otpor
was how to overcome this mentality. How do
you get people out of their houses and into
the street?
They decided to try to motivate people by
providing them with a new group to join that
would allow them to think of themselves as
daring heroes, instead of as passive victims.
They did it by making their movement the coolest
club to belong to. Like the students in Florida,
they used pranks.
They didn't use any speeches or marches. Instead,
their bread and butter was street theater.
They adapted the sensibility of a TV show
they had all grown up watching, Monty Python's
Flying Circus. One of their most famous pranks
was to roll an oil drum down a major pedestrian
street in Belgrade, with Miloševi?'s picture
painted on the side.
Serbs could insert a coin in the slot and
then could earn the privilege of taking a
bat and whacking the oil drum. The police
didn't know what to do about this. They couldn't
let it go. They couldn't permit people to
take a bat to the face of Miloševi?. But
when they arrested the barrel, because the
actual people had all fled, the government
looked ridiculous.
Otpor also decided that it could use danger
to its advantage. When the organization realized
that its members were very likely to get arrested,
but that rarely were they arrested, even held
overnight, it decided to begin to provoke
arrest. Every time any of its members were
arrested, Otpor would gather other members,
lawyers, and opposition journalists, to gather
outside the police station.
If they had to, the group would stay for hours,
making enough noise so the detainees inside
could hear them. The detainees would come
out of the police station two hours later,
or nine hours later, and be met by a crowd
of supporters. They'd give interviews to the
journalists and then go tell their stories
over beer.
The effect of this was that young men started
to compete to get arrested. I met a young
man in the city of Novi Sad who had a competition
with another Otpor member there. He had been
arrested at least 17 times. "You are a kid
in the countryside," said Vesna Dozet, who
was Otpor's Belgrade office manager.
"Your parents are unhappy. They have no work
and no money and they're getting drunk. Then
you join Otpor. You are still some kid from
nowhere, but now they've given you a cell
phone. It's your job to go to the bus station
and give a code to the driver to pick up a
package of posters from Belgrade.
Then you spirit it away and give it to your
friends and they put up the posters during
the night. Young people become partisans.
You were never a part of anything and all
of a sudden, you feel that you're a part of
something." Life under Miloševi? was very
boring.
Otpor allowed people to become their own James
Bond. Using pranks like these, and the coolest
black t-shirts and great design, Otpor grew.
In October 1998, the group started with eleven
members. Two years later, it had at least
70,000. People were joining so fast that Otpor
couldn't register them all.
And Miloševi? fell. This was not Otpor's
victory alone by any means. But it provided
Serbia with a crucial model of nonviolent
discipline and the ground troops of the revolution.
Most important, it broke the country's fear.
So, here are two examples: one is a program
run by the Department of Health in Florida
that aims to change personal behaviors; the
other was run by an underground political
movement and aimed to build national political
activism in Serbia to topple the dictator.
These two examples are about as different
as they can be in almost every way, but they
are at bottom the same idea. They work because
they appeal to what motivates us the most,
our desire to belong. We crave the respect
of our peers and a connection to the group.
Whatever the prevailing social norm of the
group is, we tend to follow it.
If we are uncomfortable following it, we will
often change groups in order to find one that
we are comfortable with. Both the anti-smoking
campaign and Otpor gave kids a new group to
belong to and a new activity that made them
feel respected and feel admired.
Our willingness to change our lives in order
to win peer approval is greater in some groups
than in others. For teenagers for example,
the respect of peers is as important as food
and oxygen. For soldiers, well, think about
this for a minute. Armies have always run
on young men drafted to fight for a cause
that they may not fully understand and probably
don't consider their own, yet they will come
out of the safety of the fox hole to charge
up Hamburger Hill.
Why will they do this? Everyone knows the
answer. They do it for their buddies. They
do not want to be seen as cowardly in their
buddy's eyes. They wanna be heroic. And because
their friends see them that way, they see
themselves that way. Another group of people
with whom the social cure works particularly
well is very poor people.
And I'm talking about the poorest people in
the world. The parts of the world that face
the greatest problems are also the parts of
the world that have the fewest resources to
be able to deal with them. People who live
in rural villages in the Third World, for
example, don't have the financial capital
to spend money to solve social problems.
Because they don't get good health care or
good education, they also tend to lack the
necessary human capital as well. But one kind
of capital they have in abundance is social
capital, their bonds with each other. Poor
people usually have far more of this in fact
than wealthier people.
Middle-class Americans are particularly lacking
in social capital. We can thank the American
dream of the big house in the suburbs, car
commuting, and the family swing set in the
backyard that's used by only our children.
It has been a part of the American dream since
the 1950s to structure your life so you see
the fewest amount of other human beings.
But for those living in rural villages or
urban slums, other human beings are often
all they have. To see what a crucial resource
social capital can be, we need look no further
than what has been the most important idea
in development in the last 40 years, microcredit.
Let's go back to the 1970s and look at what
Muhammad Yunus did in Bangladesh with Grameen
Bank. Yunus did not invent the idea of tiny
loans to tiny entrepreneurs. Other groups,
for example Axion in Brazil, were already
doing this although I'm sure Yunus didn't
about it at the time.
The genius of what Yunus did was not to invent
micro credit, but to figure out how to use
it on an enormous scale. Now why wouldn't
banks lend money to destitute women in villages?
It would never had occurred to banks to do
so, mainly for two reasons. First of all,
these women had nothing that banks would ever
consider collateral.
And second of all, the transaction costs of
determining each borrower's credit worthiness
would have been an astronomical percentage
of the tiny loans that the banks were going
to give them. What Yunus did was figure out
that the women did have collateral and he
found a way to shift the transaction cost
of determining credit worthiness from the
shoulders of the banks onto the shoulders
of the borrowers themselves.
What was the most valuable thing these women
had? Their social standing in the village.
Grameen used this. It formed women into groups
of borrowers, say five people in a group.
Initially, Grameen operated under the principle
of joint liability. If one person in the group
did not repay a loan, then no one else in
the group could get another one.
But Grameen gradually stopped enforcing the
rule of joint liability. And in the year 2001,
it did away with it entirely. Joint liability
proved not to be necessary. The risk of losing
social standing and the respect of their peers
was enough to keep women repaying their loans.
So Grameen and other micro lenders did not
have to worry about identifying collateral
or determining credit worthiness. Peer pressure
did that job for them. This made giving out
huge numbers of loans cost effective. Peer
pressure is what makes micro credit work.
Peer pressure has also been used in other
ways to solve the problems of the rural poor.
Forty years ago, in the eastern part of Maharashtra
state in India, a husband and wife pair of
Indian doctors decided to try to do something
to improve rural village health.
The project, which is called the Comprehensive
Rural Health Project in the city of Jamkhed,
has become one of the most successful and
long-lasting community health worker programs
in the world. It has greatly improved many
aspects of life in the villages where it works.
It has brought better health, but also has
made people more prosperous and helped to
soften the caste system.
[pause]
The pair of doctors, whose names were Raj
and Mabelle Arole, realized that they could
not recruit doctors to go to rural villages.
Doctors simply would not stay.
They tried for nurses. And they found that
nurses wouldn't stay either. Next, they decided
to use auxiliary nurses, who are younger women
with less training than nurses. One day in
1971, Raj Arole was visiting the village of
Saket, where Jamkhed had an auxiliary nurse.
The nurse was very good at curing illnesses,
but she had not been able to convince villagers
to change their ways in order to prevent disease.
Prevention is the very foundation of rural
health: boiling water, breastfeeding, improving
the variety of foods that mothers give their
children, vaccinations, eliminating standing
water, disposing of waste.
These are the important things and these require
behavior change. The mayor of Saket told Arole
that the problem was the nurse was too foreign
and too young. She had no children of her
own and therefore, had little credibility
with village mothers.
Then the mayor mentioned a woman from a nearby
village, named Mrs. Jashabi, who was employed
by the government as a promoter of family
planning. When he watched her work, the mayor
said, he marveled at her ability to connect
with and explain things to village women.
Part of the reason, he said, is that she was
one of them. Mrs. Jashabi had only gone to
school for four years. It suddenly occurred
to the Aroles that instead of being a handicap,
perhaps her lack of education was an advantage.
Mrs. Jashabi understood how to reach the people
who most needed reaching, illiterate poor
village women.
She knew how they thought and lived, because
she was one of them. The Aroles then made
a very curious decision. They would go completely
in the opposite direction from doctors and
nurses. They asked villages to choose a woman
from each village who was capable and intelligent,
but who was completely downtrodden.
They chose women who were largely illiterate,
destitute, married with children. One woman
I met had been married at the age of two and
a half. And all of the women I met had been
married by 13. Most were from the untouchable,
or Dalit, caste. Some were even cured leprosy
patients, women whose fingers were still mangled.
The Aroles reasoned that these were the women
who would care most about the health of the
poorest of the poor. The Aroles found that
training the women in the skills they needed
was not hard to do. The hard part was giving
these women confidence, the confidence to
speak up and to believe they had something
important to say to their fellow villagers.
Remember, these were women who traditionally
had to walk with a little broom to erase their
footprints as they walked lest others be contaminated
by them. The solution was peer pressure. Each
new trainee was sent to the village of a more
experienced community health worker.
There, she could see the woman who started
out just like herself had become bold and
assertive. She could see that it could be
done. After the initial training, the women
came back to the main campus of Jamkhed every
Tuesday to stay overnight. They study a new
health topic every week, but probably more
important, they renew their bonds with the
sisterhood of community health workers.
The Jamkhed villages that I visited look like
they're from a different century than the
villages nearby. Indian statistics have long
shown that Jamkhed villages are far healthier
than their neighbors. I attended one of the
Tuesday meetings of Jamkhed and I asked the
health workers, "What are the biggest health
problems in your villages?"
The three they mentioned were diabetes, arthritis,
and hypertension. These are rich country diseases.
Only the luckiest die of such illnesses in
rural India. But in villages in the Jahmked
program, there is no more malaria, no more
active leprosy and tuberculosis, very little
diarrhea.
Women no longer die in childbirth. Birth weights
have risen because pregnant women know what
to eat and there's no more nonsense about
starving them. Jamkhed villages have clean
water, drainage systems for eliminating standing
waste water. They have planted millions of
trees and have gardens, so they can eat spinach
and papaya with their sorghum bread.
This model is particularly interesting because
of its potential to do things that go beyond
the provision of health. It could be aimed
at bringing other kinds of services to rural
areas of poor countries that lack them. I
could imagine, for example, how village men
might be trained as agricultural extension
agents to bring improved farming practices
to their villages.
Or, and this could be the most important thing
they could do, they could start chapters of
Alcoholics Anonymous. People could be trained
to bring social norms to their villages that
express the modern world. For example, better
treatment of girl children, ending abuses
of brides and reducing domestic violence.
They could learn to help their fellow villagers
to start small businesses and get loans. In
all these cases, the best people to spread
credible messages in villages are the villagers
themselves. And the best teachers for them
are their peers in the program. If you had
asked me a few years ago to name a way that
peer pressure could be used for positive ends,
I might have said "Alcoholics Anonymous" and
not been able to think of anything else.
Now I see it everywhere and I see potential
uses for it everywhere. It's obvious, I think,
how the social cure can be used in intimate
struggles of addiction or temptation. But
some of these very personal battles now have
national implication. Take health care for
example.
One of the most expensive problems in health
care in America is also one of the most ignored.
And that is poor treatment adherence. Simply
put, we are very bad at doing what doctors
tell us to do. We have trouble taking our
medicines correctly or on time, even when
those pills are making a difference between
life and death.
We have even more trouble adopting healthy
habits, like eating better or exercising more.
Doctors are very uncomfortable dealing with
adherence and most of them don't deal with
it. Some of them just fire patients who don't
follow advice. Yet, this is a problem that
is costing us billions of dollars a year and
is responsible for untold amounts of sickness
and death.
The looming disaster of diabetes in America
is really going to be an adherence problem.
We need to deal with adherence and so far,
not much we have done had proven to work.
There is, however, proven strategy and it
is in widespread use around the globe, practically
everywhere but in the United States.
It is called DOTS, which stands for Directly
Observed Treatment Short Course. The short
course is a misnomer because DOTS was invented
to help tuberculosis patients complete a six
month course of treatment, which is not short.
Without DOTS, many TB patients stop taking
their pills before they were cured because
they didn't like the side effects, because
their lives were chaotic, or simply because
they started to feel better.
DOTS does something very simple. It provides
TB patients with a buddy, a friend, a family
member, or a health care worker, who comes
to the patients house every day to watch the
patient take her pills. It is a very cheap
strategy. In fact, it is often free. And it
works.
People who otherwise don't take their pills
will do so when someone comes to their house
to support them and hold them accountable.
When DOTS arrived in Ukraine, the cure rate
for tuberculosis rose from 57%to 81%. When
DOTS arrived in China, the cure rate in DOTS
areas went from 50% to 94%.
It is now the world standard for treating
tuberculosis. And creative organizations,
such as Partners in Health, are using DOTS
to help treat other diseases as well. For
example, to help patients take their AIDS
medicines on time. Why don't we use DOTS in
America?
We give people bottles of pills with "take
with food" on them. Why don't they also say
"take with spouse," or "take with child?"
A seven-year old would love this job. Some
people are starting to do this. Partners in
Health in Boston is using DOTS to help its
most difficult patients, the emergency room
frequent flyers, stick to their treatment
plans.
And it is working. These patients are healthier
and they're saving a lot of money because
they spend a lot less time in the hospital.
The story of Otpor is the clearest illustration
of the versatility of the social cure, of
the variety of social problems that it might
be able to attack.
This story is not just a Serbian story as
a group of former Otpor leaders are now travelling
the world training democracy movements. Their
first successes came with training the leaders
of the Rose Revolution in Georgia, and the
Orange Revolution in Ukraine.
And they have gone on now to train democracy
activists from nearly 40 countries around
the world. One group the Otpor leaders trained
was Egypt's April 6th Movement. And many of
the tactics that we could see in Tahrir Square
came directly from Otpor.
But the potential uses of the social cure
are broader than toppling dictatorship. Think
for a minute about what it was that Otpor
was aiming to create in Serbia. Democracy
wasn't their direct product. That was only
their indirect aim. What Otpor aimed to do
was to create protagonists.
It created activists, people who were willing
to abandon their couches and go out into the
street and take risks until they had accomplished
their goal. That goal happened to be getting
rid of Slobodan Miloševi?. But it could've
been many other things. They could have aimed
instead at saving Darfur, or reducing climate
change, or fighting corruption.
I do wanna be cautious here. It is easier
in some ways to mobilize people in life or
death situations than to accomplish more ordinary
political change among comfortable middle-class
people in a democracy. But there are ways
that the social cure can create catalysts
for other goals.
I don't have to tell you how important the
ability to mobilize people can be.
[pause]
I want to briefly mention one of the most
intriguing examples of the uses of the social
cure that I have found. And that is its potential
use in fighting terrorism. First, a little
background.
Why do people join cults? It is largely due
to peer pressure. This has been studied over
and over again. Young men joined gangs, for
example, because their friends do. It is almost
entirely because their friends do. The same
is true with cults. This has been studied
with the Baader-Meinhof Gang, the Moonies
and other groups.
People do not fall in with a cult because
they're interested in the cult's ideas. It
works the other way around. You meet someone
who brings you into the group. That group
is so strong, so cohesive, attractive and
persuasive, that gradually you start becoming
alienated from everyone else who thinks differently.
Your social circle starts to narrow to the
group itself. You exist in a cocoon. This
is classic group dynamics theory. There is
a persuasive argument that Islamic terrorism
works the same way. Marc Sageman, who was
a forensic psychiatrist and former CIA agent,
who has studied who become a Jihadi, concludes
that the vast majority of young men who become
terrorists get radicalized far from their
roots.
They are, for example, from Morocco or Egypt,
attending University in Europe. Or, they may
be European-born to immigrant families. The
powerful social norms of their communities
are far away. Adrift with no anchor, they
fall in with the radical group. The vicious
circle of the group dynamic radicalizes them
further.
Soon, one of the members makes contact with
Al-Qaida or goes to work on his own. Now what
if that vicious circle could instead become
a virtuous circle? If negative peer pressure
is so important in radicalizing young men,
perhaps positive peer pressure can steer them
down a different path.
In a rough neighborhood of South London, there
is a place that tries to do just this. It
is a group called STREET, which stands for
Strategy To Reach, Empower, and Educate Teens.
It was founded by an extraordinary man named
Abdul Haqq Baker, who was the former chairman
of the local mosque, which is called the Brixton
Mosque.
Baker is a Londoner, born to Nigerian and
Ghanese parents. He converted to Islam from
Catholicism in his early 20s. He's also a
PhD in Political Science from the University
of Exeter. His dissertation was about how
convert communities can work to prevent terrorism.
The mosque serves a largely Afro-Caribbean,
largely convert population. And many of those
who are not converts immigrated to Britain
from other countries. Among its worshippers
were Zacarias Moussaoui, the 20th hijacker,
and Richard Reid, the shoe-bomber.
But neither of those men was radicalized at
the Brixton Mosque. The mosque is Salafi.
It is fundamentalist, hardline, but absolutely
non-violent. Reid left the mosque because
he was dissatisfied with its non-violence.
Moussaoui was kicked out for his aggressive
views.
When these two men dropped out of sight, only
to surface later committing acts of terror,
Baker realized that he needed more than a
mosque. He needed a place where the people
who were most at risk for radicalization would
go if he wanted to do something about Islamic
violence.
So, he started STREET. STREET, in some ways,
is a traditional anti-gang organization. It
offers its clients soccer, boxing, a place
to hang out, and it can hook them up with
job training or schooling. Many of its clients
come straight from prison. And it has been
the destination of choice for London probation,
for Muslim offenders who were paroled and
considered susceptible to terrorist messages.
But what sets STREET apart from other anti-gang
initiatives, is that it has a de-radicalization
unit. If a client mentions a particular Al-Qaida
video, or a radical tract, the staff members,
most of whom are also fundamentalist Salafi's,
will watch it or read it with the client.
They point out the Islamic fallacies and just
as important, they point out the propaganda
techniques that that video or tract is using.
They show the clients how they are being manipulated,
just like teenagers in Florida. STREET's motto
is "For you, from people like you."
The idea is that the staff should mirror the
client to the greatest extent possible. Many
of the staff, in fact, were clients. They
share the client's hardline views and they
share the client's grievances. They have street
cred. Where they part ways is at the last
step.
They do not believe that Islam is in a war
with the West. They do not believe that violence
is the response. They seek to give young men
who were tempted by terrorism, a new peer
group of people who are like them in every
way but one. Does this work?
Well, we don't know for sure. It is hard to
prove a negative, terrorist incidences averted.
Baker will also not talk about specific cases.
He feels his first commitment is to his clients
and they would consider it a betrayal for
him to use their stories.
But I have talked to the people who work with
STREET in official Britain, including probation
officers, who thought the group was very effective.
London probation was actually trying to enlarge
STREET so it could take more and more of the
young men coming out of prison.
Now we will never know if STREET is effective.
The new coalition in government in Britain
decided it could not work with Salafi groups
and so, it has cut off STREET's funding. The
government did not understand that holding
fundamentalist, religious views is a very
different thing than espousing violence, and
that people who hold these views may be the
very people who are most effective at preventing
young men from falling into terror.
It is logical, really, that peer pressure
can get us out of so many bad situations,
because peer pressure is what gets us into
them in the first place. If you knock on doors
in housing projects in poor neighborhoods
in America and ask mothers and grandmothers
what it is that they're most afraid of, chances
are they will say that it's peer pressure.
"My son is a good boy," the mother will tell
you. "But he runs with a bad crowd." Peer
pressure helps fill prisons. It keeps emergency
rooms busy treating high school students who
can't tell a friend that he's too drunk to
drive, and young men who must maintain the
respect of their group by answering every
perceived slight with violence.
Peer pressure crowds bankruptcy courts with
people who did nothing wrong other than want
to buy what others already had. The smoker,
dying of lung cancer at 75, sixty years after
he smoked his first cigarette has something
in common with the woman dying of AIDS at
the age of 25.
In a sense, they're both dying of peer pressure.
We are all good boys at risk of the bad crowd.
Peer pressure is a mighty and terrible force,
so powerful that for the vast majority of
people, the best antidote to it is more peer
pressure. There are many different stories
of salvation in my book, of people weighing
babies together, doing math problems, playing
soccer, making prank phone calls, getting
arrested or sharing pot luck suppers.
A lifeline can take many different forms.
What matters is that at the other end, someone's
hand is there. Thank you very much.
[applause]
Now I'm pleased to take any comments or questions.
[pause]
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: Thank you for speaking
today. And my question has to do with social
media. We're a technology company--
>>Tina Rosenberg: I noticed.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: [chuckle] and I
curious if you've seen any examples of positive
peer pressure using social media or if you
envision anything like that happening?
>>Tina Rosenberg: That's a very good question.
And as I was working on the book, I was thinking
very carefully about this. And the answer
is I don't think so yet. I may be proved wrong
about this, and I'll be happy to be proved
wrong.
It's a bit complicated. There's certainly
examples of social media alone, being able
to exert negative peer pressure on people.
For example, Islamic chat groups over the
internet that are a very powerful force. that
can be a very powerful force in radicalizing
young men, even without having other people
face to face with them.
The chat group serves as a substitute social
group. And then we have the example that you
see most strongly in Japan of suicide groups
that meet over the internet and radicalize
each other, get each other, increase the acceptability
of suicide as a social norm, by belonging
to this internet chat group where everybody
is there precisely because they're interested
in committing suicide.
But I have yet to see really good examples
of it working in the other direction. I think
social media can be very useful to helping
to support a social cure because it's a very
good way to communicate with your membership.
It's a very efficient way to tell people what's
going on.
For example, in Egypt, this was used quite
a bit. The face group, the famous face group
of April 6 Movement was very useful to tell
people about what was happening. But the revolution
didn't happen online. The revolution happened
because they were excellent at organizing
in the street.
The other thing social media can do is it
can help you learn. It's a very good way,
especially if you live, for example, in a
repressive country, to be able to find out
about the experiences of other people who
have used this.
And Otpor, for example, has found that their
books and pamphlets and materials, which are
translated into all sorts of different languages,
are very, very frequently downloaded in countries
like Iran and other places where they might
not have other ways of learning about how
to effectively do a revolution.
But the question is can it be in itself a
social cure? There is some evidence that in
health, you can have an internet buddy and
it helps you. For example, there are experiments
that set up a person with diabetes with another
person with diabetes. And they never meet,
but they check in with each other over the
internet a couple times a day, perhaps.
Have you taken your walk today? Are you having
any problems with these medications? Yes,
I had the same problem. And that can be useful
in helping people to adhere better to their
treatment plan. But the evidence so far is
that it doesn't work as well as a face to
face program.
However, we have to take into account that
there are an awful lot of people who just
aren't gonna get to a face to face program,
but they will sit down at their computer every
day. In fact, they're doing that anyway. So,
let's not let the perfect be the enemy of
the good.
I think if these programs can reach people
that otherwise can't be reached by face to
face programs, then yes. I think they can
be useful but not quite as useful as the real
human touch.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: Thank you.
>>Tina Rosenberg: Mm-hmm.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: I'll just talk
out loud. But if we're all good boys, using
your term, why does it seem like the negative
influences of peer pressure are so much more
pervasive than the positive examples?
>>Audience Member: Can you repeat it?
>>Tina Rosenberg: The question was, if we're
all good boys, why are the negative forces
of peer pressure, why do they seem to be more
pervasive than the positive forces?
Well, there's several reasons. First of all,
like I said in my opening example of the talk,
when it's positive we don't think of it as
peer pressure. We think of it as us. My kids
are doing great in school. I don't think it's
because they're running with a great crowd.
I think it's 'cause I have great kids, or
I'm a great parent.
So, you tend to discount it. The negative
part, you look for what the bad influences
are. So, I think that's part of it. I think
the other part is that we tend not to notice
positive peer pressure so much because that's
the expectation we have of our lives. And
the news is when you get the negative part.
And there's a third reason, which is that
for teenagers, and often peer pressure is
really talked of in terms of teenagers, the
negative forces can be more powerful for biological
reasons. I mean, teenagerdom is when you're
supposed to be rebelling against your parents
and it's also a time when your brain is not
fully formed and mature.
And the last part of your brain to mature
is the part that regulates judgment, which
is a fact no parent would ever have any doubt
about. So, I think teenagers are particularly
susceptible to negative peer pressure and
it might be a little harder to do the positive
part with them.
But for adults, I don't think it is. I think
you can really find that for adults, positive
peer pressure can be even more powerful than
the negative. Yes.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: It's a question
about children. So, I have a seven-year old
and I can see how he's susceptible to peer
pressure. And the question is what I should
nurture, like independent mind-set on him
while I still can, or it's not gonna happen.
[Tina Rosenberg laughs]
>>Tina Rosenberg: Is it a lost cause? My response
to that is what you do probably has very little
effect in either direction unfortunately.
Parents, we like to think that we can have
a lot of influence over our kids, but I'm
not really sure that that's true.
I think, however, that if there's one important
thing you can do for your child it is steering
him towards a peer group that is a healthy
one. And how do you do that? I mean, you obviously
cannot choose your child's friends, but you
can introduce your child to different clubs,
to different activities that he might like,
to different groups of kids that he might
like.
And gradually, that kid will start making
friends in those groups. In my opinion, that's
the most useful thing a parent can do.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: Thank you.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: I was just wondering
if the research you've done affects your opinion
of culture, which is maybe peer pressure on
a larger scale and maybe the usefulness, or
uselessness of it.
>>Tina Rosenberg: That's a good question.
I mean, what is culture? And in the book,
I define it as however a group expresses its
groupness. What are the rituals and things
that a group does that set us apart from people
outside the group? And it's value-neutral.
I mean, culture isn't a good thing or a bad
thing. And I think it's also something that's
invisible from within. For example, if I were
a professional woman in Minnesota, I might
be wearing no make-up to work, a long skirt,
big chunky square glasses, big chunky square-heeled
shoes, and that would be perfectly normal.
If I were a professional woman in Caracas,
Venezuela, I would dress quite differently.
I would wear false eyelashes. I would wear
a tube top that shows prominently the results
of my breast enlargement surgery, a short
skirt and high heels. And I would think that
was perfectly normal.
And if I saw the woman from Minnesota, I would
think, "What are you thinking?" And vice versa.
But we cannot see that from inside. You only
see, you only consider it to be culture when
it's someone else you're looking at.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: Culture and this
whole group thing, humans are very social
creatures and it's one of the things that
kinda defines us. And I feel actually, I worked
in Human Social Behavior prior to coming to
Google.
And this whole thing of positive peer pressure,
it seems like it's been part of us since the
beginning. It actually seems like it's something
that evolved for us, evolved to make things
better.
>>Tina Rosenberg: I think that's right.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: It's something
that has been positive from the start. And
I think it's good that you're reminding us
of us. Many people seem to be unaware of that.
This is something that helps us a lot.
>>Tina Rosenberg: I think you're right. I
think it's part of our evolutionary structure
because it used to be that our groups were
our family, extended family. And so, if you
were nice to your group, your genes would
have a much better chance of being passed
down.
And we retain that. I do think that on the
positive side, there is resurgence in the
United States of the idea that we need to
be around other humans. And you see it in
many ways. For example, in real estate prices
the traditional suburbs that require a car
and have no walkability, have no town center,
the price per square foot of land in those
suburbs is dropping, where the price per square
foot of land in new walkable suburbs, or cities,
is rising.
And part of that is oil prices. But part of
it is this feeling that I think is very strong
among young people that we don't wanna be
isolated anymore. We really want to have contact
with other people and we need that. And it's
part of what keeps us healthy. There's a lot
of research that shows that our social bonds
are something that help to maintain our health
for us.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: There's one other
thing I wanna discuss. You mentioned how we
have social capital and it's more prevalent
in poor people than middle-class or rich people.
And do you think there's, I think this is
completely tied to people's happiness. I notice
most people who are middle-class or even rich,
don't tend to be very happy with what goes
on in their life, while someone in some area
of the world, well, they're just doing simple
things but have people around them to be very
happy.
Now do you think there's any way we can reach
out to maybe our supposed civilized world
who think they're so high up and say, "Hey.
We've got the cure for happiness. It's right
here within us."
>>Tina Rosenberg: There's a lot of research
going on now about happiness this whole new
branch of social science, happiness research.
And they find that actually income does not
determine happiness, you're right.
It's not that poor people are happier, but
they're not considerably less happy than wealthier
people as long as your basic needs are met.
If you're starving to death then you're not
gonna be as happy. So, I think there is a
lot to that. One very interesting piece of
evidence is studies of people who win the
lottery.
People who win the lottery don't generally
do very well afterwards. They tend to be much
less happy. And there was a very interesting
study that compared the happiness levels of
people who won the lottery to people who had
accidents that put them in a wheelchair for
the rest of their lives.
And they found that the people in the wheelchairs
were happier than the lottery winners. And
the speculation is that one reason for that
is lottery winners tend to buy a big mansion
on the hill and isolate themselves. And they
also tend to get very suspicious of people
around them because all of a sudden everyone
wants a piece of them.
So, winning the lottery can actually make
you less happy in part by isolating you from
a social group.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: One more question.
>>Tina Rosenberg: Please.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: Besides social
media, do you see any role of technology that
can augment peer pressure in positive ways?
>>Tina Rosenberg: [pause] That's an interesting
question. I think that for many groups that
form, it's obviously very important to have
technology to be able to communicate to their
members.
But social media and technology are platforms.
They're like sky writing or traveling minstrels
or anything else. You can use them for good
or for bad. So, I would say that these are
really value-neutral. And they can increase
our social bonds in some ways, but I think
in some ways they also serve to decrease their
social bonds.
Witness the number of people walking down
the street now who are only looking down at
their thumbs. We tend to do, to look less
at people around us. That's not a very original
observation, but.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: Thank you.
>>Tina Rosenberg: Thank you. Anyone else?
Thank you so much for coming today. It's been
a pleasure.
[applause]